(woman)
Neil? Neil!
Yes, honey?
Neil deGrasse Tyson,
I asked you
to take the dog out
for a walk
when I left the house
four hours ago.
Now I come back,
and this little
mother[bleep] Sputnik
has done pissed
on my drapes.
Now I've got to get rid
of those things
and get new ones.
Neil, it doesn't
make any sense.
You are
an astrophysicist.
How can you not keep track
of little details like this?
Well, actually,
it's the little details
that cannot be kept track of,
by definition.
In 1927, a German
university lecturer
named Werner Heisenberg
came to a seemingly
paradoxical conclusion,
that the more we know
about the position
of a particle
in physical space,
the less we know about
its momentum, and vice versa.
Okay, but what--
what does that have to do--
Taken in conjunction
with what we know
about the expansion
of the universe,
this brings us
to a fascinating possibility,
that maybe what we experience
as one point in time-space
could actually be
a legion of points,
which would mean
that your curtains
and little Sputnik's pee-pee
could be as distant
from one another
as we are
from the furthest galaxy.
Okay.
Well, just...
next time.
Of course, dear.
(woman)
Neil!
There you are.
What are you doing?
We have to go
to my Aunt Nelly's funeral.
How are you not ready?
I've been talking to you
about this all week.
How am I gonna find you
in your boxers
looking in
a science magazine?
[sighs]
I swear, Neil,
sometimes I think
you don't have any idea
of what's important.
Well...actually...
an idea of what's important
is as close
as we can ever come
to any definition
of importance.
Our galaxy is one
of over 100 billion
in the observable universe,
and it's 100,000
light-years across,
which means it would take light
100,000 years to traverse.
Okay, but--
But that's just space.
If we were to chart
the history of the universe
on one calendar year,
the history of mankind
as we know it,
would just take place
in the final second
of that year.
So, whether I'm ready now
or in 500 years,
well, cosmically speaking,
the distinction is meaningless.
Well...okay.
I'm--I'm going now.
Good-bye, honey.